you watch the inauguration no my wife
was given birth so I was kind of
watching it wait she's giving birth and
your half watching the entire eight it
was in labor
Oh case in labor oh you know I'm ray you
could do it you could do it and then he
was yelling so Skyy know what's going on
so I can keep making a living to
interrogate Arnage yeah so I don't know
I don't get the guy he literally trashed
everybody he did like the Eliot Ness
speech in the Untouchables the only
thing he's missing was like a
two-by-four and he was thrashing
everybody with red and blue ties so it
actually made me relax going like well
nobody's gonna work with this guy so
he'll be fine
but now he's doing this stuff to Muslims
and then I didn't know you could do that
as a president like just I'm doing this
and then you're doing it I just you know
me that you thought that Congress would
be involved I think there was another
cartoon called I'm an executive order I
just show up any time you know I mean I
think yeah very unsettling so far you
know good what did you think of Hillary
Clinton at the inauguration I thought
that was for her to show up at that
inauguration it's the second time that I
just started crying a little bit again I
just I don't know man I don't know I get
sick of people make an excuse it for she
blew it see that nobody thinks that
you're going look you lost to a guy who
said three things a week that would
torpedo anybody else's campaign how do
you do that that's like you're playing a
football game the other team throws 20
interceptions and you still you still
figure
at what point at what point do you take
responsibility they try to say they
would be like I was a bunch of I love
the racist white guy thing a bunch of
racist white guys and then it came out
of the forest and they were just going
try try from it's like where were all
these racist white guys the last two
elections when they could have voted
against the black guy they will fire I
don't mind a black guy but there's white
lady we got it stop it's gonna take the
four wheeler makuu Z so okay so not a
lot of sympathy there for Hillary
Clinton you blew it
you blew it like what's the wrong team
around you you didn't generate enough
excitement to beat this guy who I mean
it was unbelievable that this stuff that
that he was just tripping over one
coffee table after another and somehow
you just couldn't get out in front of
this guy
you